GUY IN COLUMBUS.
>> Ted: CLOSE TO
CAM ATKINSGETS TO NIT
THE CORNER.
NICE LAY IN,THEY'VE GOT
BETTER.
WE
ENJOYED CERTAINLY HIS
TIME HERE BECAUSE HE
WOULD TELL YOU IF
THEY
>> THESE TEAMS LAST
PLAYED IN FEBRUARY OF
2020.
ROSLOVIC, HOPING
FOR SEEN
TIME THIS YEAR, HIS
18th GAME.
FLYERS  Keith: THERE
ZACH WERENSKI ALLOWSYOR,
PICKS IT UP OST
TRYING TO GET IT BACK
TO THE POINT, YANDLE
KEEPS IT IN.
DOWN THE POTENTIAL
REBOUND.
>> Keith: GOOD TO
SEE THE UNIT TRYING
TO GET SET UP.
IS FLOATED
OUT TO CENTER ICE.
REBOBOKeith: THAT'LL DO
IT EVERY TIME.
WIDE WITH IT,
TRYING TO GET IT SAVE
MADE BY HART,
LINDBLOM CAN'T CLEAR.
CHANGE-UP
>> Keith: ID LIKE
HOW HE TOOK HIS TIMEME
TEAM TO WAKE UP
LITTLE BIT.
AN MORTON.
RISTOLAINEN, BIG MAN
HERE, FORWARD WHO
MISSED ALL OF F  SKIPS ,
WERENSKI AND PROVOROV
WITH THE PUCK.
HE FORCE AS TURN OVER  E
FOR MCEWEN.
A
COUPLE OF THE
PLAYERS.
--
MOVING OFF THE6 SHOTS O.
>> Keith: HE DOES
NOT LOOK TIRED AT
ALL.
SAVES, THERE IS THE
TIP BY FARABEE,  THE
SECOND CHANCE HIS BUDDYG
THE TURN OVER.
BOONE GOT THE PUCK,
RISTOLAINEN,
AND HERE IS THE HIGH
SHOT.
YOU HAVE TO PUT IT
UPSTAIRS AGAINST
MERZLIKINS.